whenever there's a major scandal that
rocks the political world it sometimes
takes a little while to figure out which
talking points uh politicians are going
to attach themselves to and in the
immediate aftermath of the fbi serving
the search warrant on donald trump's
mar-a-lago earlier this week we heard a
bunch of different things floated from
republicans we heard about this could be
the start of an assassination attempt
that made no sense there's no evidence
of that we heard about this as an abuse
of power we heard all sorts of different
things but the one that they seem to be
sticking with is the fbi planted
evidence now the trump people have not
even released the search warrant and it
seems as though they're not going to the
latest reports i saw this morning are
that they are not releasing the search
warrant there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that the fbi planted anything
there is also
it's sort of hard to believe that in a
case this high profile that that is the
approach that the fbi would take if
anything my instinct is that the fbi
would rather not have done this at all
because all of a sudden now merrick
garland's getting death threats
christopher wray is getting death
threats it's crazy what is going on i
don't think that this is something they
would do just for fun but put that aside
for a second they are sticking with the
fbi planted evidence i had half a dozen
examples for you of this over the last
couple of days and now people in greater
and greater positions of power are
starting to repeat this one here is
republican senator rand paul
who is also floating without any
evidence whatsoever
that the fbi may be planting evidence
take a listen to this and
it's it's seen as acceptable by many on
the right for rand paul to make this
claim absent any reason to believe it's
true
no people distrust so much the
government that we've gotten to the
point where for example do i know that
the boxes of material they took from
mar-a-lago that they won't put things in
those boxes to entrap him how do we know
their lawyers weren't allowed to see the
boxes go they weren't categorized
thousands of documents were taken well
rand
is there any
reason to believe
that such a thing was done because for
everybody mentioning the planting of
evidence
no one has been able to present any
actual reason to believe that that
happened how do we know that they're
going to be honest with us about what's
actually in the boxes how do we know
that was in the box before it left the
residence if the lawyers weren't allowed
to see everything so you know they've
lost a great deal of trust and it's uh
yeah so there's rand paul asserting it
and this is sort of the anatomy of a
conspiracy theory it will often start
sort of quietly as an aside with the
most partisan people trump's lawyers for
example going listen it wouldn't shock
me if they even planted evidence oh yeah
yeah yeah
and then people like fox news hosts
start uh latching onto it and we played
a number of examples of that from
yesterday and next thing you know
sitting senators and sitting members of
congress are doing the same thing it
almost seemed like marjorie taylor green
got it from an oan host here is marjorie
taylor green yesterday nodding along as
an oan host says maybe evidence was
planted and then i'll show you how later
in the day she makes it her own in all
of the all of the documents and
everything president trump had at
mar-a-lago that isn't anything that the
fbi needed to raid his home for that is
no we already talked about that earlier
the gsa approved it the the the gsa
approved the documents mailed them
sealed them and sent them to him so why
would the government give them to him
for now the government to come take them
back that's completely untrue by the way
but that's not the focus today unless
they're planting something anyway i
gotta switch back because we're
literally almost out of time words i
knew this would happen because you and i
are so marjorie taylor green saying
about they unless they plan to plant
evidence yeah
and right and then later in the day
marjorie taylor green going full-fledged
in on this tweeting quote
i think now look at the language right i
think so that's your that's your
thinking you don't have evidence i think
that there is an extremely high
probability
that the fbi planted evidence against
president trump otherwise why would they
not allow his attorneys or anyone watch
them while they conducted their
unprecedented raid
they know the consequences of an
empty-handed power move
this rings completely and totally hollow
it just doesn't pass the sniff test and
let me also talk a little bit about
marjorie taylor green's use of the word
unprecedented yesterday
um
we talked about marsha blackburn's
comment
if they can do this to trump they can do
this to anyone to which we said they
already do it to anyone the question is
will they ever do it to people in
positions of power the other one that
trump and others have been talking about
is that this was an unprecedented raid
first of all i you know i've been guilty
of this as well
the fbi doesn't really do raids i mean
this wasn't really a raid
they had a search warrant and they
served it that that's what that's what
it was it was a search warrant they
executed a search warrant so the use of
raid it's colloquially used and i do it
as well but understand that this this
was they served a search warrant
unprecedented is a big focus for them
trump said no this has never happened to
any president before
and now a lot of these right-wingers
have latched on to the idea of
unprecedented well if it's never been
done before then it must be wrong
we've never had a president who did the
things that donald trump did
so it's logical that i mean sort of like
a mathematical equation when you have
unique inputs you will have a unique
output and we're starting with the
president who did things no other
president has done it's logical it would
be to be expected that the outcomes also
are unlike those that we have seen
before and one such outcome is indeed a
search warrant being served by the fbi
on donald trump's home there is no
evidence that they planted evidence if
we ever learned that the fbi planted
evidence i will tell you that
and i will absolutely condemn it for now
there's no reason to think that that
took place